when I decided to wear the hijab I was
really happy that I finally took that
decision but after just two weeks of
wearing it uh I started to really hate
it I started to hate it's how I look in
it Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can uh so asalam alayum brother and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are well inshallah so um I've got a
sister here who's messaged me on
Instagram I get a lot of these messages
from sisters and brothers pertaining to
certain stuff that they go through and
her story really um touched me and I
believe it's a growing problem not many
people realize so I thought you know
what I asked her if she'll be
comfortable that we can talk about this
cuz I think this is something that
affects a lot of sisters a lot of women
especially in the west and also in the
Muslim world uh so we're going to get
straight into it in I'm not going to
make mention the sister's name uh butam
sister how you doing allum I'm doing
well thank you for having me as your
guest today no problem may Allah bless
you in for having being on here um so in
a nut show tell me a little bit about
your story and the problem that you're
facing uh pertaining to if I'm not
mistaken wearing the hijab exactly
please yes tell me in so we can uh see
how we can
help uh so I was born a Muslim I am
Arabic uh I do all of the five pillars
of Islam except that I have never went
to ha inah I will same me too I'm I'm a
good person um I just wore the hijab
just recently two months ago because I
fear Allah and that feeling started to
happen since the pandemic I've realized
that death would come any minute so when
I when I decided to wear the hijab I was
really happy that I finally took the
decision but after just two weeks of
wearing it uh I started to really hate
it uh I started to hate it's how I look
in it and that led me to feel somehow
depressed and um not passionate about
life and sometimes I cry because like
I'm in a struggle I don't know what to
do like I don't like the hijab but at
the same time I I need to wear it
because Allah ordered me to wear it
sometimes I wake up with some anxiety
like I would relate that to hijab
because I've never felt like this before
uh there were two times where I had a
breakdown and that led my family to tell
me all right you need to delay the hijab
a bit until you feel better and once you
feel better you can wear it again but I
felt like if I remove it maybe I would
never wear it again so I kept wearing
the hijab even though of all of the
hardships I went through and during the
past two months uh I'm watching many
videos about the purpose of it and why
Allah ORD ordered us to wear it but I
still I keep thinking about removing it
like during the day I I think about it
like each hour it's that much and the
thing is I'm okay about dressing in
modesty longest sleeves covered fully
back clothes not wearing any makeup I'm
okay about all of this but I'm not
really okay about the head scarf it's
just for me it's a big change that I'm
not used to and I really have B bad
feelings about it uh recently I started
to avoid going out because whenever I go
like I would put the hijab and yeah yeah
it's it's just it's just making me feel
really really
bad uh sometimes I feel like uh
regretting about wearing it I I don't
know why even though it was not no one
forced me to do that it was my own
decision but I I do feel I I regret the
time that I decided to wear the hijab
because how I feel recently and I want I
want to have an advice to accept hijab
and
to stop this thinking about badly I want
you to advise me like give me to give me
some steps and I would follow these
steps in order to uh just forget about
it and love it in
somehow yeah that that's shortly my
story okay may Allah bless you Sister
inshah may Allah preserve you um before
I start I want to praise Allah subhana
wa tala the most merciful the most trust
all praise His glory and gratitude
belong to him uh you know Sister um just
hearing from your story the reason why I
wanted to to do this um like record it
because there's so many women in your
position you're not the only one number
one first thing you need to acknowledge
you are not the only one feeling like
this not just Muslim men there's also
non-muslim woman and even Muslim men for
example uh for me when I first came to
Islam I said to myself waking up for fud
I dislike it yeah at times I hated it
now hating it you need to understand
because there hating a h what Allah said
which can take you the F of Islam we're
not talking about that kind of hate it's
the struggle of it so when you're saying
you hate it I know what you mean in the
sense of that it is hard and look you
need to understand this is normal it is
understandable it's about working with
it you don't hate it in the sense of
what Allah legislated so one thing you
need to understand sister is that as you
know that Allah subhana wa tala has
created jna and N Hellfire and Allah
subhana wa tala of course is going to
test us a lot of people forget that we
are in this life as a test and it's
going to be a test sometimes we think to
oursel that if we do what Allah
legislated us to do it'll be just easy
like for example praying it should just
be easy like we should enjoy it we
shouldn't have any problems with it
that's not true when Allah subhana wa
tala legislates us to do certain things
there's going to be hardships because
Allah says in the Quran don't say you're
going to say I I believe and not be
tested it's not going to work like that
even when it comes to pursuing pursuing
Halal when somebody says you know what I
had girlfriends or boyfriends before and
I want to leave this and now I want to
do things the Halal way they think that
because the you are pursuing Halal Halal
is going to be easy it's not sadly it's
a test from Allah it becomes hard so to
me there's a few factors in place
because number one like you said before
and modesty is not just a hijab on the
head like you said wearing baggy clothes
there are women who wear the hijab they
wear tight clothes there are women who
have baggy clothes don't wear the hijab
and there are those who wear the hijab
correctly top and bottom and then there
are those who wear the hijab the top and
bottom but they their tongue is foul so
hijab is something that applies to men
and women and the way we conduct oursel
the way we speak the hijab the outer
garment Etc but that's why Allah says in
the Quran that we have sent clothing to
cover yourselves but the clothing of
tawa Allah talks about the clothing of
tawa which is something that is um yeah
it's something deeper so to me sister
firstly I want to understand your family
Dynamics does your mom wears hijab or
your sisters or your family members yes
my mother wears the hijab but not my
older
sisters okay may I ask
roughly how old are you roughly are you
in your 20s 30s and 30s okay so
personally I would say this sister yeah
um you you don't my asking have you
always been practicing like praying yeah
yeah since I was a kid okay and you have
never wore the hijab right yeah I've
never wore it just just while praying of
course but I have never wore the hijab
outside the home okay and actually since
I was a kid I I I I would say I didn't
like it much but I didn't know that it's
like uh like I should wear it I didn't I
didn't know it's a big
thing okay so you know your friends that
you have do they wear hijab or they
don't wear hijab uh my clothes is
different doesn't wear hijab okay um
okay so you need to understand firstly
your surroundings are going to have an
impact on you the people that you're
around and I'm not saying they are
necessarily bad what I'm just saying is
that they are going to have an impact on
you um for example if I have a group of
friends that have a certain specific way
of lifestyle they have a certain
lifestyle like it or not they are going
to affect me one way or another so
that's number one number one is very
important for you to understand that you
make sure you are around people who are
that you can relate with secondly the
society that you live in because you
said to me that for example you would
look at your old pictures and you would
cry yeah yeah yeah exactly what when you
say you would cry what do you cry about
so when you look at your old pictures is
it oh my gosh look how beautiful I look
or look how good I look in my hair what
is it that makes you
cry it's actually many reasons I would
say first uh I would relate like I was
happier so like recently I've avoided
looking at my old pictures and I compare
like myself wearing the hijab and my old
pictures without the hijab I feel like
oh without hijab is way better okay good
so you see here What's happen to Sister
there's a book called It's in English
it's called Beauty sick I talk about
this it's um if you can buy it or even I
can send you as a gift inshallah this
talks about this is WR written by a a a
non-muslim woman so she talks about the
pandemic of sickness of beauty amongst
women now a lot of times sister we think
that for example that some sometimes
sisters come and say I choose to wear
the hijab or I choose not to wear the
hijab you've heard this before yes okay
so I don't believe this concept and I'll
tell you why we of course we have the
will like free will like choice we
believe in the and we have free will to
make decisions but our decisions are
affected so believe me sister the fact
that you are taking this choice you need
to understand you believe in Shan right
yeah now Shan does not want you to do
things that are pleasing to Allah and
this can sometimes come in different
ways so the fact that you are having
these thoughts and feeling this way to
me is Glad Tidings I would be shocked
and surprised if you said to me I wear
the hijab and I don't feel anything it
is very normal for you to feel like this
why because the Shan is on your case the
Shayan will never rob a house that is
empty he will look at the house there is
nothing to steal so when he's looking at
you he's seeing that you pray your Salah
you're doing etc etc etc you're a good
Muslim woman and now you're taking it to
the next level by wearing the hijab so
in his head but uh he's going to try to
make attack you and make when you look
at your old pictures he's going to give
you waswasa look how beautiful you was
look how nice you looked by the way if
you don't mind me asking sister are you
married or not married cuz there's a
reason I'm asking no I'm not married
okay please be honest with me do you
think that this makes you feel as if
your chances of getting married is
lessened does this ever come through
your head like you know what you looked
more beautiful your hair showing do you
feel like wearing the hijab I'm less
likely to find somebody cuz I don't look
as
beautiful maybe but I always thought
that
I'm because I see myself like without
hijab and I used to be without hijab I
see myself like I could prove somehow
myself better like in work in work place
or good or talking to people in general
even to friends like whether it's a
potential husband or not I feel like all
of the people around me I would be
better without hijab I don't know it's
just feeling okay the people that you're
around from your workplace to your
colleagues friends Etc they they don't
wear
hijab some of them they
do the others they don't okay the ones
that do what do you think of them
because they're coming to the workplace
and they wearing hijab what's your what
how do you see them like do you not see
them as like a form of support how do
you see them yeah I used to actually
Envy Envy those ladies who wears the
hijab because like they are doing what
Allah ordered us but I never thought
that I would have hardship wearing it
like I would say oh it's really great
that she is wearing hij inah I will wear
it soon but I never thought when I wear
it I will have all of these hardships
okay so good so first thing we need to
understand is this sister yeah you do
you accept Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
created the heavens and the Earth the
whole universe yes okay would you agree
that it is not impossible for Allah to
help and Aid you to carry on wearing the
hijab
again please sorry so do you accept that
for Allah it is not impossible to help
you in keeping the hijab on yeah it's
not impossible good good okay now what
Allah subhana T does sometimes is he
wants to see the effort of the servant
it is not impossible for Allah to make
you keep the hijab on forcefully it's
not impossible Allah can make you do
that but Allah what Allah subhana T does
is he likes to see how much effort you
are going to put in so the test is what
sister how you're feeling with the
anxiety how you feeling of not feeling
maybe beautiful enough Etc how you feel
maybe Shayan comes and says how you look
in front of your colleagues on a
potential husband Etc these are Shan
coming and telling you as if these
things are in your hands for example he
makes you feel as if to find a husband
you have to look a certain way so we say
what that even if you was wearing aab
your face is closed yeah and even if you
didn't come outside of your house we say
Allah will send you a husband to your
door so who who who is in control of
finding your husband or who is in
control of these other factors you or
Allah yeah yeah of course Allah good so
what happens sometimes is Sister Shan
comes to and makes us think we are in
control so that's the reason why a lot
of Muslim women and non-muslim women the
way the reason they dress up in a
certain way where some of them wear
tight clothes or mini skirts or they
beautify their s they get their lips
done they get the ears done they get
their nose down they get their eyes down
their eyebrows down their hair done
everything done why because they think
to find a husband or to find someone or
for men to approach me in a Halal way or
for non-muslim women in a Haram way they
think I have to do all of this so I can
find a person in Islam we say no we say
of course it's good to look after
yourself brush your teeth groom your
hair there's nothing wrong with that but
to think that by doing these things that
I would have a like more likely chance
of finding somebody this is not from our
religion we say that if somebody
observes tawa if somebody is holding to
the legislation of Allah if somebody
fights for example you are now in a form
of jihad because you are fighting your
inner desires to not take the hijab off
your family have obviously because they
care about you they've said you know
maybe till you you know get used to a
bit but what you're doing is you are in
a state of jihad against Shan right now
A outright Jihad and you I believe are
winning this war because you could have
take it off you could have say you know
what this is getting too much all I will
say to you sister the following this is
not going to last forever I want you to
do something number one do you do
important because the thing is I really
like I have this thought that will will
that be lasting like one year or two
years because it's really hard you know
I'm scared that it will be developed
more like that feeling bad feelings
about hijab I'm scared it will develop
more and I will have more bad feelings
about it after one year or two years so
I'm really scared about that the thing
is I don't mind going out without makeup
wearing baggy clothes it's just the head
I don't feel like myself anymore okay so
Okay the reason why you don't feel like
yourself is because you're getting
closer to Allah in the sense you need to
understand you are now your level you
need to understand sister there's
different people in different D in in
the sight of Allah subh tala you are now
turning your back to the DWI stuff and
to the materialistic stuff and you are
now taking it a step further so
therefore you are now more of an enemy
to Shan because before you know you was
not that I'm seeing those who don't wear
it are bad but at the end of the day
Allah has commanded the Muslim woman to
wear the hijab so I will say number one
do you do
your to be honest not regularly okay
sometimes I remember sometimes I forget
okay is very important sister because it
protects you from waswasa right now I
think the main thing here is waswasa and
you are looking at old pictures and
Shayan is giving you whatw of you know
the opportunities you're going to miss
this that Etc you need to understand
though that on that when you do wear the
hijab that at the end of the day it's
going to be one less thing that you'll
be questioned about and the thing is you
are putting the effort in like we all
are in different ways for me it was
waking up for fud waking up for missing
fud is a bigger sin than you not wearing
the hijab bigger sin but the point is
what sister I realized when you put the
effort in like for example you look at
maram yeah like may Allah have mercy on
yeah that she when she was given birth
she needed food and Allah tells us in
the Quran that she had to shake the palm
tree you know this yeah yeah okay why
does why does she need to shake the palm
tree why can't Allah just give her food
and she's a woman imagine you're giving
birth do you know how strong a palm tree
is it's very and I don't think a woman
or even a man for that matter can shake
a palm tree but the point Allah is
showing to us here is what you if you
fear Allah Allah says in the Quran inah
talak if you fear me I will give you a
way out from places you can never
imagine so we put the effort inam what
she do she shook the tree it's not that
she could shake it but she put the
effort in Allah saw the effort and Allah
gave her the food to eat you look at M
Alam M Alam didn't have to hit the sea
with his stick his staff yeah he didn't
have to hit it but he has to do the
action what does that show us you do the
action and you put your trust in Allah
now you are in a state of fearing Allah
because you want to please Allah because
like you said you might die tomorrow Etc
so now the battle is going to be
decisive now why I would say is this it
is impossible that Allah will burden you
more than you can bear impossible Allah
has said clearly we will never burden a
soul more than it can bear there are
factors that you have you need to take
out number one friends that make you
feel that you wereing the hijab for
example or you even being around them
seeing them with their hair out it's a
fitner for you you seeing them showing
their hair and you can't I would say it
might be hard but my sister you come
first Allah says in the Quran save
yourself and your families so if it
means that this friend if this friend is
supportive that's fine I'm not asking
you to like cut ties number one number
two you need to understand that the
society has a role in your decision-
making factors do you really believe
sister that the Western woman and even
some Muslim women for this matter do you
think they want to go and put injection
in their lips in pain and make their
lips bigger do you think they want to do
this or they have no choice but to do
this maybe they have no choice good
there are women who go and get
implants in different parts of their
body they get their eyelids done they
get their face lift they get their teeth
done some of them get their nose done
they break their nose my dear sister why
would anybody in their right mind go to
these levels of causing pain to their
self why just to look good Society has
pressurized them and made them feel ugly
that's the reason why sisters feel upset
and they cry why and some sisters even
take the hijab of why and they say I
choose to no you don't no woman chooses
to disobey Allah why do you do it why do
women do it because they feel I look
less beautiful or I won't get the
opportunities so the point is what if
you look at it Allah says in the Quran
have you seen the one who has multiple
Masters one two three and the one who
has one master they can't be the same so
when I talk about multiple Masters the
beauty industry the opposite gender your
friends peer pressure family these are
things that you it's in the back of your
mind which is making you feel ugly I
don't look good there is something wrong
with me it's the society but deep down
you want to please Allah deep down you
want to so this is where the battle is
happening it's not that you want to
disobey Allah but the reason why you're
going through this is because of this if
you lived amongst every woman if every
woman was wearing the hijab every woman
would you feel like taking hijab
off no not really good you know why cuz
that would be the norm because it's
become the abnorm today when you go out
and not only that these women they wear
their hair hair this color eyebrows
everything is done so in your head
you're thinking and I know for women
women like it's in their F in the sense
where they like to be seen and for us
men we like to look we are that's our
weaknesses so that's why Allah subhana
wa ta'ala is testing the woman why
because her beauty Allah is testing them
by telling them to cover up and for us
men Allah tests us because Allah knows
we're visual creatures men like to look
and Allah tests Us by lowering our gaze
telling us to lower our gaze so I would
say this will not carry on forever it
will not I've been through Test sister
believe me the tests have gone very very
like to the point of breaking but W I'll
tell you one thing sister one thing that
I will tell you is that never ever will
Allah subhana wa ta'ala let you down
never like never ever think that
alhamdulillah so like
AAR would make me feel like better like
what what should I do to make me feel
better like wearing the
hijab so I will say this is number one
number one the first thing I will say is
this do you pray your five times prayer
yes okay good alhamdulillah so one thing
that I'll say is your is very important
very very
important yeah make sure that you do
your I treat my like
I treat my like a Salah so you do not
miss it you know why because your
protects you against evil eye magic
waswasa all these kind of stuff so this
what you're having and there was man the
came to the prophet alh wasallam and he
said oh messenger of Allah I think about
things about Allah that I would rather
drop from the sky and be eaten by birds
like this I get evil thoughts like you
know you say you have bad thoughts about
hijab yeah
this man he this companion was saying he
has evil thoughts about Allah and his
messenger he says I hate these F so much
I rather fall from the sky and birds eat
me do you know what the prophet Sall
wasallam said to him the prophet said
allahar allahar allahar he said for the
plot of Shan has dropped to nothing but
waswasa meaning the Shan is trying to
stop you from praying you're not you're
not stopping praying making you commit
shik you're not doing that shik trying
to get you to do major sins you're not
doing major sins and now he's looking
and saying this woman not only that now
she's wearing the hijab the only Power
he has against you is what wasasa you
look like this look how beautiful he
looked in your old pictures you're not
nobody's going to want you do you get
what I'm trying to say yes this is the
key so sister it's not going to carry on
forever but you need to say to yourself
that this hijab I'm wearing is a form of
had and I am doing it for the sake of
Allah and I am not going to take it off
whatever happens when you internalize
this like ibraim Alam when ibraim Alam
do you remember he had to do a
sacrifice yes for his son no the first
sacrifice he he had to do was what not
yes Allah yes there was a Commandment
that he's going to sacrifice his son but
before that for example when you decided
to wear the hijab the first sacrifice
was not wearing the hijab but rather the
first sacrifice was what that I submit
my will and I'm going to wear the hijab
so you had to do a sacrifice internally
internally you said I am going to do
this that was the first s sacrifice that
was the first step then the second
sacrifice was actually putting the hijab
on if you don't internally do the
sacrifice you can't externally do the
sacrifice so for you you internally said
I I am going to do this for the sake of
Allah then you took action like ibraim
Alam took action by Slaughter trying to
slaughter his son yes yes do you know
what kind of FNA that is to slaughter
your
son yeah yes it's big okay yes what did
Allah do when he was about to do
it um I got to
explain exactly exactly Aram yes so now
I'm asking you question what do you
think Allah's going to do when ibraim
Alam was ordered to do something and
even though it was the hardest thing to
do he went to do
it what did Allah do Allah replaced it
with something which was an animal yes
yes what do you think Allah is going to
do when you are sacrificing this and you
are adamant saying I am not going to
take this hijab off I don't care if the
entire Globe comes against me I am going
to stand in front of Allah on and say
this hij Allah I put it and kept it on
for no one but your sake alone and when
you do that sister and when you
internalize it and you have your good
days and you have your bad days but ask
aid from Allah anytime you get evil
thought ask Allah Allah Will Never Let
You Down sister and believe me believe
me
trust me my dear sister it doesn't
matter how you look Allah will Aid you
in your work to your marriage to
everything believe me once you put Allah
first and you sacrifice the D for him
Allah believe me I'm telling you as a
witness a live example I've been a
Muslim for 10 years Allah has taken me
and put me in places and W Allah has
given me me things I cannot even I
cannot begin to tell you and I did
sacrifices my family kicked like my
father kicked me out the house I got
slapped you know my my my um um
Community called me all kinds of stuff
but W when you stick true to Allah Allah
will give you a way out and W the very
family members some of them come to
Islam from my from from my side yeah and
believe me and I look back and say I
could have easily come and say you know
what I'm going to leave this religion
there's too much problem for me my dad's
causing problem here my mom is causing
problem there you know uh my mom was
always suppored but the family this Dad
the community the
W no I am going to stick and when you do
that sister Allah makes you taste the
sweetness of IM believe me so I would
say it's what you're going through is
normal it's it's a test Allah wants to
see how much you genuinely want to do
this and the moment
the moment you feel weak ask Allah to
Aid you I'm telling you Allah is going
to make this easy for you inshallah
inshah so do not cry inshah and even if
you cry you cry to your lord anytime you
feel like something in your heart
whatever cry to Allah have no shame cry
to your lord and say oh Allah Aid me and
help me against the pl of Shan indeed
Shan is an enemy Allah says in the Quran
and take him as an enemy sister because
on he will come and he will say I did
not do nothing but call you I didn't
force you so therefore sister imagine
you're going to wear this hijab for what
another 10 years 15 years 20 years 25
years 30 years God knows what life you
have for an eternity the fact that
you're going to stand in front of Allah
and that you made this sacrifice this
hijab hijab that you wear might be the
reason why Allah says enter Jenna just
just just Salah okay that's good but
because of this sacrifice this hijab
might be the reason you enter Jenna so I
would say you know be firm inshallah I
will get you in contact with some with
some sisters that you can talk but just
know it's
normal Aid ask Allah's Aid and W I
promise you that inshallah inshallah
Allah will give you a way out just be
firm inshah
so like during this uh period is it okay
if I had a feeling like some sort of
regret is that okay because yeah yeah
look sister look look these things
understand I know Shan makes you like
look at you you regret it you hate all
was was sister I don't care what any
kind of thought comes to your head I
hate the hijab I look like this I regret
it no problem you said that believe me
you know these thoughts they are not you
you know these thoughts I hate I regret
I should have not why did I do it this
is not from you this from Shan just know
that when these thoughts come
you need to acknowledge this is not
coming from you this is coming from Shan
because do you love Allah and his
messenger yeah of course good so someone
who loves Allah's Messenger will never
come and say I regret I hate no no no
this is the waswasa from Shan so don't
think this is from you and hate yourself
rather you hate Shan this is from Shan
and what about the days that I wasn't
wearing a hijab first will be forgiven
yes come on sister not only for given
the the prophet told us they will be
turned into Good Deeds if you sincerely
repented all of the time that you didn't
wear the hijab we say that your bad
Deeds are turned into Good Deeds CU
you've sincerely repented and you've
changed and you're wearing the hijab now
and W let me tell you sister W believe
me Allah subhana wa tala will turn them
all into Good Deeds so ignore the Shan
and you know all about your pictures are
still there but some people see it so
maybe Shan comes you and says that you
know some people still got pictures you
know what's the point wearing it you not
maybe he says stuff like this even if I
love those days like when I
remembering let me tell you something
let me tell you something I come from a
Jia before Islam yeah sometimes I look
back and I was like oh it was so fun it
was so fun look this is me I I'm Al I'm
a nobody but you know these things come
Froman you
say bye-bye what I have now
alhamdulillah so these things are going
to come to It's new noral it's not
abnormal you know so don't think these
things are abnormal these things are
normal slowly slowly they're going to
disappear cuz you're you're a new person
now you're changing so slowly slowly
you're going to realize they are going
to leave you one by one and you're going
to forget these days believe me once
this test is over you're not even going
to remember you're going to for you're
going to say I was I was thinking like
this why was I thinking like this this
is what you're going to say insh in do
you have any other
questions I think that's
all thank you so much for strengthen my
IM no sister may Allah bless you we're
here you know at your service you're our
sister we are proud of you you know you
guys are you are the backbone of this
umah you know you when you we the hijab
you are symbolizing that you are a
Muslim woman and alhamdulillah you know
we we we as men you know Subhan Allah I
don't think I could have do what you
guys are doing so just know as your B we
are proud of you be strong you are symb
realizing look me I don't looking like
and there's non Muslim that have beard
yeah this is not a symbol is likely to
Islam there's non Muslim men who have
bigger beard than me so the point is
that you wearing the hijab shows clearly
you are a Muslim woman so may Allah
preserve you and don't forget you are
carrying the Ayah of the Quran on your
head you are carrying the Ayah of the
Quran on your head every time you go out
you say that and you're going to have
good days and you're going to have bad
days yeah this is normal good days bad
days just firm it but believe me Allah's
help is going to come Allah's promised
that be firm inshallah and I'm going to
connect you with some sisters and they
would help you further inshallah thank
you so much thank you no it's it's a
pleasure sister may Allah bless you and
preserve you um and W and I make Dua for
you may Allah subhana wa tala protect
you against the evil PL of Shan and his
wasasa uh you know may Allah Grant you a
righteous husband ald may Allah give you
ease in your work in your family Affairs
inshallah and inshallah you are going to
be a means that other family members
start wearing the hijab and you are
going to get the because you encourage
them because of you inshallah you don't
know maybe you're the reason why Allah
subhana wa taala is going to allow your
family members or your sisters who don't
wear the hijab by looking at you and
admiring you and saying you know what we
want to wear the hijab like our sister
inshallah that happens insh inshallah it
will happen and don't ever doubt that
yes okay thank you so much no may Allah
bless you I'm going to get you in
contact with some sisters and they will
help you further if you have anything
you need please message me on Instagram
and I will love to help inshallah yeah
sure thank you may Allah bless you may
Allah bless you and your Jihad is going
to be successful inshallah don't ever
forget that alhamdulillah thank you in
inshah may Allah bless you Salam alikum
allum byee I I will I will send you this
video in after this have a look but yes
W the reason I done this sister is
there's so many woman in your position
so many and W I believe inshallah with
your permission if you allow us this
will be an encouragement for them to
understand that this is normal going
through this it's normal I've been
through it not with the hijab but other
stuff you know waking up for f I've been
through it myself so it's normal and
Allah says we will test you with also
fear he says death loss of life loss of
wealth and also fear this anxiety that
you're getting is a test from Allah and
then once you pass it you're going to
act like it never never happened uhhuh
by the way what if I couldn't find
friends wearing a
hijab um I would say I'm sure Jordan
there must be some friends uh ask Allah
I would say ask Allah like look I'm not
saying leave your friends if they are
bad influence leave them if they are
telling you oh you look so beautiful do
they say to you oh you look much better
without hijab do they say this no not to
she is supportive are you sure she
doesn't say stuff like oh you looked
better in no hijab no no she do okay if
if this is kind of friend good but I
would say also get sisters that you are
sharing it with it's very important that
you have female friends that wear the
hijab because at least you have
something you know that you're not alone
you know very important look you know
what I can do I would try to find
out that in that the country that you're
in if there's any sisters and get in
contact with them oh that would be great
thank you yes please make sure you do
that friends like the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said a good friend is
like somebody who sells musk even if you
stand next to them and do nothing you
are going to leave smelling good and a
bad friend is like a blacksmith even if
you stand next to him you're going to be
in Smoke and dirt so a good friend is
very very vital sister so make sure you
find those women who wear the hijab that
can help you so you feel a part of it
inshallah inshallah when you will be in
Jordan you will give some lectures
um I'm not coming but if I do come I
might do I will let you know inshallah
inshallah no problem may Allah bless you
insh take care thank you thank you so
much no problem take
care